Before we continued as video. I just want to say, thank you,
Dashlane for sponsoring this video more on that later.
You know, there's one misconception that I hate on the internet.
They always think that PMs don't do anything or that they don't add value.
So what do you say about that?
I think it's hard because I think like there are,
there are certain roles where it's,
you don't necessarily need a PM if it's purely like technical,
it's like sometimes a PM doesn't add any value there.
But I think working is like kind of the central point across all these
different, like product functions and helping unblock, um, in general,
like being a PM, the day-to-day PM role is not like glamorous, right?
It's a lot of unblocking, a lot of escalating to other people,
a lot of getting people to do things and managing the project itself.
Like the day-to-day aspects of it are.
So like not having someone to help do that is one challenging for everyone to
get their job done too. It's like, I think having a vision and spending,
having someone spend time thinking about the overall strategy and not saying
like, okay, the, we only care about building this one feature,
but how do these sets of features like actually manifest itself into like a
product that actually is something that's special is like very hard to do when
you're just focusing on a very local problem. Right? Um,
it's you need like someone to look at the problem holistically to help manage
the pieces, help break it up and set timelines. Um,
and they get like kind of the work all done. Otherwise you've seen it.
Other companies like, um,
there are other companies out there that don't necessarily have PMs and it's
really engineering driven.
And the problem is that I've heard from other friends who work at those
companies is that you build a really,
you want to build a really cool features and the really,
really like flashy stuff that like you would use,
but no one else outside of you or the company would want to ever use that,
lets you build really cool features, but no one wants to use them.
And so it's honestly around like how do you build,
how do you build features and how do you get someone to understand what the
users actually want?
So you also mentioned like product vision,
like that's pretty important because you can't just focus on execution,
but how do you even get better at product vision since you usually only vision a
few times?
Yeah, yeah. Right. I think you're always thinking about it. Okay.
You always see it,
but I think it's a really deeply understanding in order to get real product
intuition,
you have to deeply understand what the user problem or customer problem is.
I see. And that's either doing research or use it utilizing data and asking the
questions that you need. Um,
I think those are the feedback loops that tell you like,
Oh and reading market research, looking at trends,
things like that's where it gives you a vision of like, Oh,
this is where the market is headed. Or this is where,
this is where people are having trouble. Um, and that's helps like craft like,
Oh this is like on videos, right?
Like that means like discovery might be really hard or people don't have sets of
controls. Right. And so in that case,
like you have to really understand all these external signals to help build
that intuition.
Yeah. Thanks for debunking this misconception.
It seems like it's a very messy job and you're trying to make things on
all the time. Yeah. So,
because it's so messy to like unblock people and do all that crap,
like what would make your job easier for different functions?
Like as a software engineer,
how can I make your job easier as a data science test? How can I make your job?
Yeah. I think it's all about just setting like timelines and deliverables.
Like if you say,
if we need this piece of analysis and you can estimate it correctly to say,
yeah, I'll have it done by the end of the week.
And it helps plan things because it's a chain, it's a chain reaction, right?
Someone does an analysis, you have recommendations,
you then work with design to help like scope them out.
They tell you some deadline and then engineering can help. We can work on it.
And so at that point, if those deadlines are not actually like accurate,
then it postpones everything and it makes it pushes things out.
And so it's all about just like getting the proper estimation and chunking it
out into the right set of milestones to make sure you continue to make progress.
Right. So, so being good at estimating how long it will take certain things.
Yeah. Right. So do you prefer if someone, uh,
overestimates how long it is or underestimates.
Mean it's always under promise over deliver. So it's a good model.
That's always the one thing that you could keep in the back of your mind. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. I wasn't very good at estimating when things would be done.
It's not necessarily just like a sweating up front, how long it is.
It just like if you get three days in the seven day analysis and you say, Oh,
it's going to take longer just telling people that like, Oh,
this is actually going to slip a little bit and then you can plan that.
That's true. Okay. So what about PMs? Uh, how are they evaluated then?
Because, um,
it might be kind of hard because some products are easier than others.
For example, if the product is already booming versus a product that's crap.
Yeah.
I think it's a couple of ways.
I think you can do a one on like the product strategy that you have.
Like did you set the right vision and does it,
and it may not necessarily be that like you succeeded, but it's also,
if you failed, like,
did you learn why you failed that can help iterate on your product strategy
coming up? So it's not just, you don't get rewarded just for succeeding.
You can actually get rewarded for failing, but failing in the right way.
So you had the right hypotheses, did all the research, what you built,
just didn't work out and then you learn for why it didn't work out.
That makes your product stronger. It's a second. So that's one,
the second one is like pure execution, right? It's like,
did you execute on what you were going to say? You were going to do?
Like if you have six months and you have to build something in six months,
did you actually build it and ship it in six months?
And the last one is more like, kind of cross-functional it's like, did you,
were you able to motivate your team? Did they like working with you?
Were you able to unblock them?
And how was your relationship with like other teams outside of your core team?
And like, did you were able to get like a lot more out of other people? Um,
and did they like doing it?
Do you think the skills to pass the interview as a PM
are the same as the skills to be a good PM?
Cause I feel like for software that's not true. Yeah. Right.
Software. It's like, I think you have to pass some bar artificial bar.
Like you have to know how to do all these recursion problems,
but like in theory you never do it ever in all algorithm problems.
They never do it. In theory and practice and software engineering,
I think in product, it actually gives you a good signal. I'm like,
can you take an ambiguous problem and like break it down if you take,
if you have a really ambiguous problem and you're not able to put a framework in
place to analyze it, you're never going to be, it's going to be really,
really hard to be successful. You can learn it for sure. Um,
and then if you can't like have fluidity with some data and saying,
here's a hypothesis of why something's down and say,
here's how it would prove it. Like you're going to struggle. Like it's,
I'm not saying it's all learnable.
I think it's just like there's effort that you can put up front to problem
solving, to learn and to say like,
here's how I would think of stuff that definitely helps.
So I would say it's definitely a more fair.
I think the one thing that isn't necessarily super fair at being someone that's
like young is like experience,
like the fact that people are looking for more experienced people,
like in a role, like you have two more years of experience, like,
and people don't take you for that role or two years less of experience for
someone else. Like, and the CA and what they say is like, Oh, you're not,
you don't have experienced to be in this role.
I think that's a little bit more of a cop out because it's a matter of,
it's just a matter of like, how does this person have the right set of skills?
Like not necessarily experience map.
That's true. So for you, uh, especially during your time at Facebook,
what skills do you think were most important to your success?
I think at Facebook, it's a lot of just communication, like over communicating,
realize when you work on a really under your team itself,
like people understand all the context for why you're doing things and you don't
need to, like, you can get really in the details.
But if you take a step up and look at your manager, your manager's manager,
other teams, they lack all like the individual details.
And so it's like keeping those people informed to say, you're working on this.
This is why we're working on it makes your life easier. Um, yeah.
So I think that's like one of the biggest skills you've learned,
especially at a big company is like, how do you manage,
like outside of your core team? Because at a small startup, it's easy.
Cause everyone knows that you're working on your finite resources.
Like everyone in the company knows exactly the problems that you're working on.
Whereas a bigger company it's like people are working on so many different
things. It's hard.
Hm. So communication matters a lot. What do you hate most about being a PM? Ooh,
I think there's, it's hard. I think.
There's a lot of unflattering things you have to do as a PM.
Like you have to like commute over-communicating you have to unblock and having
those,
like having to like step through politics and like,
and people's incentives is kind of, you're all on the same team.
And the fact that people sometimes act like a different differing agendas is
really difficult because you have to find why if they understand it and then
sometimes like it comes to a head. If those,
if those things are not like aligned. And so in that case, it's just like,
there's a lot of unnecessary roadblocks for you to do something that you want to
do. And then like, everyone's agreed to, um,
I think that's like pretty frustrating because it's inefficient.
Can you give me an example of what office office politics actually are?
Cause I'm on my previous video,
I said something about office for data science and a lot of people
mistook me thinking that I hate office politics, but that is not true.
I think off of policy, office politics are great,
but I just wish I was better at it. Right. Like I think it's great.
Like I watched billions bunch of office politics. It's not great, but, but,
but it's, it's so juicy. Like I like it. So anyways,
can you give me an example of what office politics actually look like.
In real life? I think it just means,
I think it's less like contentious is what people think.
I think it just means like you're working with a team, that's not your team.
Right. They have different goals and like they have different incentives.
Like if you're on that team, like you have a goal that you want to hit.
Like you're not willing to work with another team because it doesn't mean that
it doesn't help you hit that goal. And so why would you ever want to do that?
Right. And so it's more of like,
how are teams aligned and structured to make sure like, you can reduce that. Um,
because like that's just inherent. People are always going to be like, Oh,
I like, I'm looking out for my team. Like if that's not the case,
if like you can't help my team, like why would I work? But as in general,
you're a part of the same company. So like,
you have to understand where they're coming from. Nothing really juicy, so.
Right. Exactly. It's not crazy like backstabbing
or just like, yeah, like it's fair. It's fair to be.
Fair. And people come from the right place.
So I just want to take a second here to talk to you guys about dash lane.
Dashlane has been a huge time-saver for me. So as you know, I buy a lot of.
So I hate entering my password and my credit card information every
single time. And now with Dashlane, I don't have to,
because every time there's an online form, it just fills everything out,
automatically saving me tons of time.
And it keeps everything secured. Plus,
if any of your personal information gets leaked in the dark web,
Dashlane will alert you because they are actively monitoring the dark net for
you. When you do see your passwords get leaked,
all you have to do is press one single button and it will change all your
passwords for you. You know, I used to have one password for everything.
I use all the apps, all the websites, which is kind of dumb,
but now I take my security pretty seriously. They also have a VPN,
so you can access content everywhere and prevent prying
advertisers, eyes, just joking. But seriously, if you're interested,
you can get it for free on your first device. If you go on
dashlane.com/joma and for my viewers, you can get 10% off premium.
If you want to use the VPN or the dark web monitoring.
Now that's pretty cool. All right. That's pretty much it. All right.
Do you have any tips for people who want to transition into PM?
I know we talked about that a little bit, but just like more.
Concretely. Yeah. I think like in general, it's like,
just continue to be thinking about like products, right.
Or like products that you use, whether it's like an iPhone, a watch,
like even it doesn't have to be actually like an, uh, an electronic product.
It can be anything. And he's like, okay, how would I make this better?
And then just breaking it down in your head, like, Oh, who would I,
who would use it? Why would they want to use it? Where does this, like,
where does this like a breakdown? How can,
what are the things that I can build that make this better?
I think it just helps you really think about like a framework. Right.
And then I think like,
just like understanding more of like developing a hypothesis of like,
why you think something's a case and trying to like prove or disprove it. Um,
so that helped you like develop like the critical thinking.
I think understanding data in general is like, is definitely helpful.
Like being able to learn to write your own queries. Like it's not necessarily,
like, it just helps you understand like how the things are done. Um,
and if you need to, you can do it yourself. Um, and then I,
I think it's just like mostly just like curiosity and just the ability to like
really want to dive deep in a product. Like for example,
I was never a software engineer. I didn't know anything about API as,
I didn't know anything about developers platforms and what tools they build,
but I worked for three years on building developer platforms, API APIs,
and like really technical solutions without knowing any of it to start.
And after that, it's like you dive deep, you understand problems.
And you're like, okay. Yeah, here's what the solution is. And you learn.
And so it's all about like, how do you understand what the problem is? You know,
the customer or the user or the developer?
Uh, I guess what I meant more was, um, you concretely,
did you use any resources to help you prep for progress?
I know, I think the best way is like,
just to do as many mock interviews as you can. How do you get, um, I mean, you,
if you know someone at a company with your friends, like, just ask your friend,
if you just like, give me this prompt and then just like go through it as like,
there's no substitute for like real experience,
if you think about it in your head,
but actually having to communicate and tell people, um,
is a much harder problem.
The second thing is just like making sure you understand how to communicate and
like explain things. I think people think about it for me, example, for example,
I think of all the things in my head and it's like, Oh, I understand it.
But communicating,
proving to someone that you understand a problem is a much harder thing,
but what you can do that it tells them that you understand,
you really can understand what the problem is.
And so I just say like do a ton of like mock interviews with friends.
Like there's some resources online. I don't, I didn't look at any,
but there's some resources online that like really go into like what the types
of things you should look at are there's a lot. Yeah. There's a really,
there's a lot of resources out there.
And the other thing that is help that are helpful,
like is even if you just do basic like look at some basic consulting
frameworks, like, can you just help?
Because understands like how people think about frameworks and breaking things
down.
But those friends, they have to be in PA they have to be a PM. Right. Okay.
Yeah. I mean, it's kind of hard for some people who don't have PM friends. So,
um, I mean, I guess you could read cracking the PM interview. Yeah. I read that.
I didn't get the job five. I think it's pretty straight.
And a lot of companies will tell you like how to,
how to prep and they'll give you resources to prep.
And so you just do it and you go through it.
I think a lot of times I see people when I do interviews,
like the resources are all there, but you obviously didn't read them.
Um, and so like, it's not like it's not rocket science to go through.
This is just all about the structure and the framing that you have.
[Inaudible], let's go to like the personal stuff. All right. More about you,
you know? So like, why did you choose PM one?
I wasn't good enough to be a software engineer.
I was, you were strictly mediocre,
but you wouldn't want in general.
Like, for me, it's like, it was really interesting to build things or to see,
like to write like a couple of lines of code and see something happen
immediately. And I think that was like where it was like, Oh, I want to,
I don't want to work in like client services. I don't want to do other things.
I want to work. I don't want to wait even sales. Right.
Because I want to go like actually build the things that like people use.
And I was like, if you, I'm not a software engineer,
like what are the types of things you can do? Right.
You can start a company or you can work at like the product manager and own a
product and build it from end to end and have a team built team team,
working with you to build it as well. And so it was more around like,
how do I just, I see all this good, these cool things in Silicon Valley,
like outside of Silicon Valley, like, how do you,
how can I build something like that?
And so it was more around like that type of mentality and product gave me the
best chance to do it.
Did you build anything when you were a kid or when you were? Yeah, yeah.
I was actually super into,
I thought I wanted to be like a mechanical engineer or like something like a
material science or stuff like that. Or I,
we have this class in high school where we built, um, we built engines.
We built, like, we actually measured, we built like cosmic Ray, uh,
uh, finders. And we were able to kind of do really cool. Uh,
we were able to do kind of build really cool things in a class.
And I think that was just really fun to get experienced building like mechanical
stuff.
But then I took a couple classes in college around like building web apps. Oh,
I love that. I thought it was really, really cool to just build something. Um,
and I think I went to San Francisco.
Like the first class you take is like CS one Oh six, a I'll really.
Anyone, but everyone.
Has, I think 95 or nine is optional,
but 95% of the undergrad class now takes it seriously.
My class was like 1,200 people wholly. Um, but the last project you build is,
I mean, the projects you build are a one, you build a rip breaker.
I can't believe you screwed up. I can't believe you did that too,
because I still see some people building that. Yeah. It's a very common,
it's a crime.
And the last one was to build a watered down version of Facebook. Really.
It had the basic functionality of friend requests wow.
From writing on things and that'd be easier. Yeah.
And so the ability that you can actually see that and build it, um,
that he was definitely a little bit yeah,
you got some of the starter packages for it,
but like the fact that you were able to build and see like,
Oh my lines correspond to this stuff. Um, it was really cool.
Wow. No wonder why Stanford is such a good school. Holy. All right.
So a little bit more philosophical. Yeah. You know,
what are you working towards in life? Yeah.
I think it, they might want to definitely at some point,
want to like start a company or join something really small. Right.
I think the problem,
the problem I see a lot is that people start companies for the sake of starting
companies,
because they think it's like a quick way to get rich in the end of the day.
Like that's not going to happen.
Like the odds are so much against you that like it, the only way it's going to,
you're gonna give yourself the best chance of succeeding is if you are really
passionate about that area and willing to spend 10, 15 years, like building it,
even if it re even if it might fail. Right. And so it's like,
I think the only way I would think about starting a company is like, if,
if I had enough conviction and motivation and a specific problem to solve it,
otherwise I think joining a company super small,
where you help build the product from scratch,
but not necessarily come with the idea.
It's something that's really fascinating because it's like,
how do you bring something that's super small to scale and like,
hopefully grow it. Um, so that's kind of where I want to go. Um,
I think I've learned some pretty, really pretty good skills now in order to.
Nice, wow. A true builder. You are. That's nice.
But what kind of problems would you like to solve?
Like what are the areas that you care about?
Like,
there's a lot of stuff that happens just on just like getting people to use more
things. Right. Like, I mean, I work on products, they do the same thing. Right.
But I think there's something around like some of the social good around like
health, right?
How do you make things health more accessible on some of the more societal level
problems that people are trying to tackle, but as much trickier, right. Um,
health has won wellbeing. What you care about. That's what I care about.
I want to see something, I want to see something.
I want to see something that really makes an impact in people's lives.
If it's like money transfer to,
to rural countries and making it easy for people to bank. Right.
Like I think that's something that you can just see impact of a product you're
building. Like, yes, you can build a product. That's cool.
But seeing people use it in a way that like actually changes their lives,
like I think is something that would, I would love to do. Cause as mentioned,
it's more mission driven. Cool. Um, yeah.
I think we're doing stuff around like sports is also super interesting.
Like maybe there's so much like so much data out there to make better decisions
from like your sleep to your health, to your performance. Um,
that doesn't exist.
I'm just saying that's a really super interesting piece as well as education,
all of these like things where people can, like, you can actually see,
people have fundamental changes in like wellbeing is I think something that
is interesting on work.
Nice. Nice. Yeah. Just to make sure that your incentives are, are true.
So if every job paid the same, what would you do?
Oh, if every single job paid the same.
I personally, this is going to be out of left field,
but I think I want to work in like the state department,
the state department and government.
I think it'd be really cool to be like working, um,
foreign affairs and work like with kind of governmental policy across like
foreign policy across like different parts of the world. Um,
I think it's hard to get into it.
I think it's like the process FICO working in the government is like
ferry antiquated, um, where it's just like,
there's no real good career trajectory. Um,
but I think that's like super interesting.
That's true. That's true. That's cool. So what about now?
Like what do you do outside of work?
Let's not talk about what do you do outside of work?
I love being like, I love being outdoors.
I love like how of being can tell being hiking. I like go hiking.
I love going skiing. I love traveling. Oh yeah.
I'm going to Japan in a couple of days.
Oh really? Yeah. Did everyone's going to Japan? Cool. All right.
Thank you so much for coming in. Yeah, appreciate it. Yeah. All right. See ya.